il est venu donc participer à ce
challenge pour apporter une nouvelle
réponse donc aux réunionnais sur une
pathologie que beaucoup connaissent sans
forcément pouvoir l'identifier il s'agit
des traitements de remonter par
capillarité cette modification à la base
des murs qui nous embêtent qui fait que
sans arrêt nous sommes obligés de
repeindre de reprendre donc nos habitats
mais aujourd'hui on a surtout une
réponse qui va être à la fois économique
et une réponse qui va être écologique
économique tout simplement parce que ce
procédé géomagnétique des traitements de
remonter par capillarité va être un
procédé qui est autonome pas de piles
pas de batterie pas d'énergie consommée
donc pas de pollution de notre
environnement aujourd'hui il faut savoir
que c'est un des rares procédé qui vous
apporte une garantie bien sûr décennal
mais qui va également vous apporter une
garantie de résultat si vous n'arrivez
pas à traiter aussi nous n'arrivons pas
à le traiter ensemble nous vous
remboursons votre investissement - une
petite vétusté comme la loi nous y
autorise voilà donc 10 % par an ce n'est
rien ce n'est rien de prendre donc cette
responsabilité de se dire je peux
traiter ma maison